محيط المجمع القضائي في العاصمه
الباكستانيه اسلام اباد وقد اصبح ساحه
للمواجهات بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين من مؤيدي
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
المواجهات اندلعت مع وصول عمران خان الى
المحكمه للمثور امام القضاء في تهمه تتعلق
ببيعه هدايا ثمينه ابانه وليه منصبه
اطلق رجال الشرطه للتو الغاز المسيله
للدموع باتجاهنا وتعاملوا معنا بعنف اثناء
تقدمنا صوب المحكمه وبداوا بعد ذلك بضربنا
بالحروات انظر هذه اثار الهراوه اصابوني
بجرح في راسي
ومع بدء المداولات الغل قاضي مذكره اعتقال
خان وارجا الجلسه الى الثلاثين من مارس
الحالي ليعود خان بعدها برفقه انصاره مره
اخرى الى لاهور تطورات دفعت رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني شهبا الشريف الى وصف تصرفات
عمران خان بالغريبه واتهمه باستخدام الشعب
دروعا بشريه وبالقاء انصاره القنابل
الحارقه على الشرطه الم يكن محيط المجمع
القضائي هنا في العاصمه اسلام اباد ساحه
المواجهات الوحيده بين الشرطه ومؤيدي
عمران خان بل امتدت ايضا لتشمل محيط منزل
عمران خان في معكله بمدينه لاهور
بعد مغادره عمران خان منزله متوجها الى
اسلام اباد اقتحم مئات من عناصر الشرطه
المنزل مبررين ذلك بتعرضهم لاطلاق نار وهو
ما نفته عائله خان
في البدايه قالت الشرطه انهم سيرفعون
المخلفات الموجوده في محيط البيت ثم
احضروا اليه ثقيله وفجاه بداوا يدفعون
البوابه وعندها اعترضنا وطلبنا اظهارا
مذكره التفتيش ولم تكن هنالك قوه من
الشرطه النسائيه فقط الشرطه وفرقه مكافحه
الشغب
الشرطه قالت انها صادرت اسلحه وذخائر من
منزل خان واعتقلت عددا من انصاره قبل ان
تنسحب منه لاحقا وهو ما نفته العائله ايضا
سمير النمر الجزيره اسلام اباد